the upwelling of positive feelings that
we have when we are quote happy is also
an evolutionary adaptation and it really
signals that what we experience is
beneficial for us something that really
enhances our lives or protects us or
gives us joy like a newborn or a new
relationship or something like that but
if we were constantly happy we wouldn't
see any threats that potentially are
around the corner so there is a
basically a positive and a negative wave
that goes through our lives negative
when we perceive things that are
potentially threatening to us and
positive when there are things that are
really our life enhancing having said
that I believe that we have an
underlying positive attitude towards
life we prefer to live than not to live
and again we have to have that so the
baseline is not zero where we have some
days above zero and some days below zero
but the baseline is positive in itself
and Greek they have two different words
for happiness
one is hedonic and that's the typical
pleasure of happiness you know other
joyful like oh this is wonderful and
great and then they have a work called
eudaimonia and that is that positive
baseline that simply is a joy of simply
living there is so much happening in our
lives that we pay attention to and and
quite frankly you know the little
devices that we carry around on help
very much because our attention gets
totally absorbed into that attraction
from these little devices and we get a
little bit of dopamine all the time when
we get all information information is
valuable instinctively so we want to
know what's happening and what's going
on it's true for gossip and it's true
for why we watch the news but the
problem is that our attention is so much
absorbed in that that we rarely if ever
pay attention to just being present and
that is really what mindfulness and
meditation is trying to balance out a
little bit so that when the mind quiets
and you actually are at home in your
body
that that that distraction fades away
and you actually get in touch was that
underlying happiness that the Greeks
call eudaimonia just to recognize I'm
alive just that simple fact is in and of
itself positive and that does not waver
that is always there and that quality of
happiness is there even when sad things
happen you know so you cannot be always
happy because if a loved one dies you
know obviously you're not happy you're
sad but within that you can have still
the joy of living so those are two
different aspects of happiness that I'm
I think are very important to
distinguish